all right so welcome to the beginners
games lecture and my name is Aviv I'm
going to be here for the following
they're coming several weeks so I'll be
doing these if they happen again and
today we are going to start with origins
game on chestnut come right Arjun and
let's see the opening so Hajin starts
with d4 and his opponent plays g6 which
already tells us that it's going to lean
towards one of those modern defenses
right or Kings Indian defense or maybe
something else so many times
d4 players like to play the move c4 just
as if black plays Knight f6 but you
decided to play a four so it's like
almost like you transpose right into the
regular modern defense that starts with
E for g6 and 24 so Bishop g7 here again
white has a bunch of moves and many of
them are possible and hard to say that
one is necessarily better than the other
you played Knight f3 when I used to play
chess which I don't anymore for some
reason but I used to play Knight c3
almost automatically and I notice that a
lot of players play 9c3 because it's
kind of a flexible move in the sense
that they don't commit their g1 knight
yet they say maybe under some
circumstances I'm going to play for
example f4 so for example if you don't
intend to push your C pawn to here
anyways so maybe you want to consider
playing this move first and then let's
say the opponent plays d6 and then again
I'm just saying it is an option it
doesn't have to not the only one you can
still play Knight f3 here and it's fine
but like f4 is an interesting very
interesting choice and then to plane out
of three the possibility of building a
really strong center and I really like
it because sometimes it interferes with
my opponent's ideas if he wants to play
Knight for example this Knight coming
let's say to d7 then I like to push my
pawn my e pawn to e5 okay so let's go
back to the game and we said in the game
not if three happens still fine h6 now
I've been playing chess
I've been around chess for over thirty
years but never in my life have I seen
this position before this is a brand-new
position for me now it could transpose
into something that I've seen yes but
right now it looks like Greek why why
the move g6 h6 was played I have no clue
is he trying to prevent some piece from
coming to g5 maybe but there seemed to
be no urgency at all to play a move like
this so of course if I'm if I'm white
I'm kind of happy to see it and already
I have an idea in mind
notice that I'm thinking to myself okay
and and Arjun sees this is your game
let's see if you can help me a little
bit when you look at this position and
you pretend that you are the black
player even though you're white where do
you think the black king is going to end
do you think he's gonna be happy in the
center okay so do you think he's gonna
go left and Castle queenside or is he
gonna go right and Castle kingside when
you see all that looks like it right
because to cancel the other way is going
to have to get rid of a lot of pieces
right he has to let its queen out his
Bishop out all those guys this guy this
guy this guy all those he has to let
them all out and it has to mean pushing
some pawn and even then since white is
most likely to cancel the other way he's
going to Castle kingside this way then
it's going to be very easy for white to
attack right if black chooses to put his
King on this side so we conclude that
normally in these positions the black
King goes this way he wants to castle
here
right of course not right now there's a
knight there so with this in mind I'm
thinking myself okay if he wants to
Castle here and he already played the
move h6 how can I make his life harder
how can i punish him so what do you
think would be a good setup to try to
punish the opponent a little bit and
again very very good and absolutely
correct I want to put my bishop on e3
like so and I want to put my next move
is going to be Queen up from here and
here and we know that the Queen and
Bishop on the same diagonal like this is
called a battery in just you don't have
to remember it just to mention it when
the Queen and the [ __ ]
are going to be lined up against the
spawn right now this point is very well
protected by a rook by a knight and by a
bishop but this Knight wants to see the
light of day right he wants to come out
some day and if the king wants to cancel
then he will change places with the rook
but then the rook will be missed
defending the pawn can you ready
anticipate that you guys understand what
I'm saying with a queen and Bishop on
this long diagonal so let's say for
example first of all maybe you can play
Knight f6 but after Knight f6 maybe I
can play e5 and already the poor knight
on f6 is going somewhere it didn't mean
to go so that is one thing that can
happen okay a second thing is that we
can just play Knight c3 normally defend
the pawn and still the Queen and Bishop
are going to be lined up against this
parade six month so that was interesting
okay so in the game Knight c3 again a
normal move nothing terrible about that
definitely a very playable move ecigs I
really don't like this move who can help
me and tell me why don't be afraid to be
wrong by the way but okay yes say again
because white plays the move d5 okay but
before I even look for a move for white
like I didn't even I didn't even think
of a move for white but already as soon
as I saw the move already something like
my instincts said like I don't like it
why for example if let me let me put it
this way had black played this move then
I would have liked it then I would have
said look how he is doing things
harmoniously he is doing it like
everything works together notice this
pawn is controlling this square the Jeep
one is controlling f5 the deep one is
controlling a5
nothing is in the way everything is
controlling something and they're
working together just like a team when
you don't do that when you do this then
notice how the e pond and the Jeep on
are attacking the same square but e 5 is
very very weak and more sell look at the
dark squares look at all the darks
whereas f8 e 7 DS
yeah f6 all those dark who has they are
very very weak because of that one what
was the sense of putting this pawn here
if you already developed your Bishop
this way you don't have to let the
bishop out so compromising the dark
squares is not a good idea I'm against
it okay now again I'm thinking to myself
alright in this kind of a position what
do I want to do is white now in the game
I know that you play the move Bishop c4
and um I'm not saying it's a terrible
move but in my opinion I think that I
have a very very good long-term plan and
we already mentioned it before I want to
start with the move Bishop probably to
e3 maybe even to f4 but III seems to be
a really good square for the bishop and
now in this position my my plan is to go
Queen to d2 and again pile up against
this pawn make life very very difficult
for the King on this pawn notice that I
haven't cancelled with my King as white
which means maybe I'm going to Castle
queenside if I do that then I can afford
to send those pawns the H and G pawn
pawns up the board to attack so for
example I don't think it's so easy for
black to make a move let's say that he
makes a move like Queen Knight to e7 I
assume that's why he played a six to
bring the knight there now I'm going to
play Queen d2 and now we see part of the
plan that was something that I was
talking about before and here it's even
more obvious can black now comfortably
castle no why not exactly the Queen and
the bishop are already lined up to take
the pawn all of a sudden casting has
become a little bit of a problem for
black he can afford to castle it's a
legal move but it's gonna cost him the
pawn once that rook moves away from here
after the castling he's gonna be on f8
then my bishop is just going to munch on
that pawn and it's gonna be very happy
I'm gonna do it for sure so black has to
do something that he didn't really meant
mean to do
for example maybe push h5 maybe push g5
but either one of those moves
making a big weakness and again I wanted
to remember white has not Castle
kingside he hasn't committed his king
this way most likely he's going to
cancel the other way so for example
let's imagine something like let's say
this and let's say white castles just to
give an example and now of course black
can also cancel when you look at the
position before you even look for moves
just by an optical look which Kings
seems happier here how many of you think
it's the blocking how many you think the
blocking is happier how many think is
the white king that's happier everybody
agrees of course you don't even have to
be a strong chess player just by you by
looking at it you say wait a minute
the king is supposed to Castle where he
has a fortress of pawns who is close to
it and is guarding it and it's hard to
get you well I think that the white
structure really fulfills that statement
the black one doesn't already I can see
how maybe I can use my H and G pawns to
create a big harassment like maybe
already at some point my H pawn is ready
to move up the board and play h4
uncomfortable very very uncomfortable
for a block he is gonna get under an
attack and that's a very good way to
start a chess game if you're white so
again will grow back to this position
and again understand that the urgent
move is to develop the equation
developed the Queen's start an attacking
position get ready to bring the king
this way and push those pawns to attack
you thought to yourself I'm assuming
Arjun that you were thinking I want a
Castle kingside therefore I need to
develop my f1 Bishop right that was your
thinking that's why you play Bishop c4
or partly okay but you understand how
maybe Bishop e3 and Queen d2 would have
been more to the point right
okay so Bishop to d2 c4 and he plays the
move c6 again as soon as I look at this
move it's like if I'm looking at the
board and let's say I'm looking away
let's say I pretend I never looked at
the board before I'm looking at it again
one thing immediately comes to me
immediately strikes me as all what is it
what is the most obvious thing in the
position something that kind of screams
at you when you look at the position
what do you think it may be yes bad
development by black exactly and to
complement it what's really weak in the
black army in the black area the dark
squares exactly look at them starting
from this one on c7 d6 e 7f 6f8 even a5
they are all very very weak and our
first instinct is how are we going to
take advantage of it now when he makes a
move like a six and then c6 he is
telling us something what is he telling
us he has a move in mind he wants to
play a certain move yes
d5 he cannot be more declarative right
he cannot be more obvious to say I
played six I played c6 I'm ready to take
my D pawn and push it up the board now
how can we play a move that does two
things at once a interferes with the
plan of playing d5 comfortably
second of all try to start taking some
advantage of the fact that the dark
squares are not very strong what do you
guys think Arjun
say again yes one of those moves is
indeed to play the move d5 a very very
interesting move gaining a lot of space
and well let me tell you what if I get
to push this pawn further to d6 that
point is going to be a real like a bowl
in the throat right it's like a thorn in
your side it's like something that you
start really bothering you and yes if I
get to push it but if what is your
alternative if you take it okay then
I'll take it I still have a policy you
want to push it if you take again and my
knight takes I would rather be white any
time of the day for this kind of a
position look my knight is superb and
untouchable in the center and it has a
bishop to support it I'm just ready to
Castle and bring my rook to the e-file
with a big attack and you see this pawn
d7 how do we call this kind of pawn a
backward and I saw both you're right
it's isolated because it has no pawns on
the adjacent file to help them and it's
backwards because it's going to be
awfully hard to get it to d5 do you see
black going d5 in this game
only if Wieck is superbly cooperative
right his wife is like the friendliest
Christmas friend right he's going to let
you do it
otherwise forget it so this is
tremendous tremendous for white so d5 my
goodness what a move I want to hear
another move that has something to do
with this idea taking advantage of
things here yes also interesting to play
e5 yes and of course here black has to
be super careful because if I get one
free move is white my knight from c3 is
going to jump to the e4 look at this I'm
showing with the arrows if my knight
comes to here and then of course he
wants to visit the d6 square then the
black position is near bankruptcy right
like really really bad so maybe in this
position black will have to play d5 and
of course I know that I can take the
pawn on passant here I can take it but
probably no probably I'm just gonna just
put my bishop back on that square and
now this pawn on e5 is extremely
annoying
it makes this Bishop on g7 look really
really weak and again I'm gonna use my
pawns on the King side to try to attack
the King okay but d5 did you suggest
that argent I really really like even
better I have to tell you okay in the
game you played the move Bishop e3 and
what is the big drawback of this move
now that well this is the plan right you
want to play Queen d2 but what is the
problem with it what can now black do he
was preparing for it he did it in the
game yeah the problem of this move is
that now black can play this move and he
is he feels like a spring coming out
right like a spring that was pushed
pushed pushed and all of a sudden it
sprung out like he burst and he gained
space he hits the bishop with the tempo
it hits your center right that pawn hits
his center it's gonna you have to get
rid of the e pawn so you have to save
yourself Wow
something really really funny happened
here now when you face something like
this you have to say okay maybe I made a
mistake maybe I shouldn't have allowed
d5 but now I have to react to it
properly if you take and he takes you
are doing him a favor
why why by taking this pawn you
doing black a favor I think that there
are like even two reasons for it who
thinks that they might know don't be
afraid to be wrong by the way
okay I'll June you want to try well
that's gonna happen anyways right
whatever happens my bishop cannot stay
on c4 right so what do I capture with my
e-pawn or if I move the bishop
immediately the bishop has to go back
agreed yes
now I'm saying why should a bishop go
back immediately and leave the pawn on
e4 why shouldn't I trade
why should I just first move my bishop
not trade yes which gets really strong
okay in the game you took and he took
okay he took like this which is also I
guess playable but I would have taken
like this and what good thing now
happened for black that what does he
have now that he didn't have before a
small thing yes yes but yes the bishop
on c8 if you look at this position and I
would have asked you here what is blacks
worst piece absolute worst minor piece
all of you would have to say that this
is this Bishop on c8 it has to be this
hey it's the only one who can't make a
legal move at all period all the others
good or bad if this can make a legal
move this Bishop cannot make any legal
moves what's more it's going to take a
lot of effort to help but make a legal
move even after this was played this
bishop is still looking funny yeah he
can make one move but that's just about
it now by taking and allowing him to
take like this wow this bishop was just
liberated all of a sudden he was
somewhere in the basement behind a lot
of covers and all those covers are moved
and the big basement door is like
squeaking out and he sees the light of
day that's not what we want to allow our
opponents to do sorry no so that's one
main reason also when you trade this
pawn I want you to think of it look at
the e pawn and then look at the black a
pawn that can recapture back which one
of them is better this one or this one
all of you will say the e4 pawn white
it's more active it's in the center it
has more space so why do I want to treat
this guy for this guy let me pretend
that I just moved the bishop and for now
I'll just move it here doesn't really
matter let's say I play Bishop to here
just as I move and already you can see
that black is left with the same
headache that he had before the bishop
on c8 is stuck let's pretend that he
takes to trade anyways and I take back
well what do we see we see that I did
trade my e pawn but I didn't trade it
for the black e pawn I trade it for the
black D pond that's an even exchange
that d5 pawn was a decent pawn I don't
mind trading it for this one so that is
a very good trade for me and look at the
bishop still stuck and very passive on
c8 my knight by the way improved it went
to the center so the long story short
here in this position it's better off to
leave the e pawn which is protected and
not trade
okay so traded and he for some reason
decided to take with the C pawn I would
have taken with the e pawn for sure
because I'd love to see my c8 bishop
come out and now you played here again
it's kind of funny that every move I
have a comment
but sometimes the position requires it
you have to save yourself okay my bishop
is being attacked
I have several moves to choose from one
is to go where you want to hear the
other one is here and then two more
moves on the diagonal and I have to say
that if I have to choose to move in this
position most likely I would either give
the check to gain the tempo and maybe at
some point I would be able to be willing
to trade it for the bishop of the night
or I will go all the way back to eat you
keep it as a defensive piece because
when I go to b3 I'm thinking to myself
how am I ever going to crack open this
very strong wall on d5 do I have any
resources and do have an e pawn that I
can hit the center
no I already traded it that d5 is like
the strongest point on the board for
black I don't want to have my pieces
look at it because there's no way they
can crack it right imagine that you had
the hammer about this size and you have
a concrete wall about this size it's
going to be very hard right so it's it's
a it's a bad war I don't want to be
there so for example I can get in our
tempo for my development I'll play a
check
if he plays Bishop d7 heck even if I
trade for it you know then it's better
off but again like I said the other
choice is to play Bishop to eat you now
the bishop is a bit quiet but later on
in the game maybe I can do something
with it in the meantime black has a very
bad bishop in soap on c8 so on we go
with the game sorry
so we have Bishop e3 a6 okay not the
most urgent move it seems like
developing the night and trying to
cancel might be more urgent and now you
cancelled and I'm a little puzzled by
this because what do we say what do you
think is the most logical move in this
position yes Queen d2 no question about
it
queen bee - it's very hard for me to say
that I would have played any other move
here but Queen d2 this move is very very
tricky I don't tell my opponent if I'm
going to Castle kingside Oh Queen side
it's always nice if you can keep your
opponent in the dark when he sees this
movie says wait a minute is it going to
castle this way or that way that's very
nice to keep your opponent guessing
especially when sometimes he gets it
wrong and then it gets very demoralizing
it's really sad about ah I thought he's
gonna do this and he ended up doing that
instead of just casting it's like oh I
know his king is here that means he
cannot attack me anymore and besides
what do we know we want the Queen and
Bishop battery to be all over that
little tiny age born we love it we just
love it when this now let's say for
example he plays his night out somewhere
let's try to play Knight f6 because now
maybe I want to bring my Knight to g4
and I'm gonna attack this Bishop and
protect the pawn now maybe I will play a
little move like maybe h3 not let the
night go there and again notice how hard
it is for block to castle his H pawn is
hurting so again he needs to play
something like g5 or h5 we already
discussed that much in the beginning of
the lesson
it's a weakening move that he probably
is going to regret later but how else to
castle it's going to be very very hard
to castle otherwise so Queen d2 was very
very good here
okay so in the game we cancelled he
decided to play b5 okay notice again
that all this pawn mobility just makes
his Bishop on c8 look really really
silly even if he gets to here or here
that Bishop is a very very bad piece
that is something that is white we
should keep in mind okay so a3 now I'm
assuming that you are really worried
that he might play the move before was
that your concern maybe but you have to
say to yourself easy really benefiting
from before or easy or maybe he is not
so for example let's say that you are
trying to provoke it I'm gonna play a4
and I'm dying for him to trade because
that's gonna be very useful for me so
let's pretend that he says no and he
does this and I will move my knight
let's even say - eh - just for the sake
of attacking the pawn on here and let's
pretend that he wants to defend it
because he doesn't feel like losing it
and now I can use my C pawn either I'm
gonna play c3 or maybe even I will play
the move c4 to try to open up the
position and my pieces are active I have
to say that most likely I will play the
move c3 really really like it now my
bishop can swing back to another
diagonal or fresh diagonal and my knight
is going to come back with power because
well it can after you take and my knight
takes and my knight can just get better
so really really like this for white
okay you decided to play a three he
played ninety seven queen - E - okay
reasonable move connecting the rocks
again D - is my favorite move D - and
again the problem is how to castle okay
now neither five very very good and you
decided to play route d1 so I'm assuming
that you are saying I cannot move my
bishop because if I move my bishop then
maybe he is going to take my pawn on d4
right well there's some truth to it but
on the other hand maybe des it's not so
simple
let's for example say that I play this
move just because I really really like
my bishop I really think that
this night gets to take the bishop then
blacks bishop on g7 is gonna have extra
powers so let's say I move it now I'm
assuming you thinking just takes right
and takes and Bishop takes and now for a
moment it looks like white just lost a
pawn and he's very sad black is ready to
cancel and all that but what can white
play in this position say again please
you mean the white this Knight - move
back - where - here I don't want to go
backwards I gave up a pawn when you give
up a pawn you have to think yourself how
can I be aggressive right if you give up
upon and then you have to go backwards
chances are that your game is very bad
and I can tell you sometimes you have to
do it but here you have something and
somebody already said it taking on d5
Knight takes d5 well as you can see that
pawn seems to be attacking it but the
Queen here is pinning it to the king so
forget about it there is no way to to
take that very nice
I agreed this is very very nice okay of
course black can cancel the game will go
on but I can assure you already that
white cap is pawn back and he is all
these pieces developed all the black
pieces are still here this Bishop on d4
is very very vulnerable imagine what's
gonna happen my rook is coming to d1
attacking the bishop and the Queen all
the way behind it imagine a rock on this
beautiful d1 square very hard for black
so probably in this position if black is
smart probably is not going to take the
pawn and if he's not going to take the
pawn then that means that we could
afford to move our Bishop and save it
from that evil Knight now we control the
e5 square maybe we can play Bishop e5 or
Knight to e5 at some point and we can
always defend our pawn whenever we need
to
so okay in the game we played Luke 81
and the opponent just canceled I have to
say that I would not have missed the
chance to get rid of this Bishop this
Bishop can become very good in a second
is going to go to f4
and on therefore it's a good piece it's
doing a lot it's in the center King side
Queen side it's a very smart piece so my
knight would just take it get rid of it
and then that makes this bishop look
stronger okay so in the game like I said
castles and Queen d2 well the idea of
Queen d2 was available far before right
a long time ago before and now if the
Queen d2 he is probably going to take
our Bishop on e3 so let's not allow it
and let's protect our bishop this would
have been a very nice move notice how
everything is protected now I can afford
to move just like before I can afford to
move my bishop and now I'm controlling
this beautiful square on e5 most likely
either my knight or my bishop can land
there whenever I need to this gives me
at least a decent game okay so Queen d2
King 87 okay why I don't see why first
of all the knight is not protecting it -
and the bishop is protecting it
second of all like I said I would just
take this bishop with the night because
that Bishop could be good so he decided
to play this 90 - okay again not a bad
plan because right now when I'm looking
at this Bishop on b3 and I'm looking at
this Knight they're not doing a whole
lot they are very very weak so the only
way to do something is by moving the
knight repositioning it to another
position to here and maybe pushing the C
pawn and getting my bishop back into the
game otherwise it's going to sleep
forever on the diagonal but I don't want
to lose my bishop I want to first save
my bishop
that climb is good but first save the
bishop okay so 92 Bishop d7 that Bishop
is going to be bad forever Knight to g3
again I'm going to sound like a broken
record but once again I don't want to
let him take this bishop even though in
the game I don't pick the Terkel but I
want to preserve it so I would save it
first then bring my knight achieve three
that will be okay he played here and the
knight took what a surprise why did he
take the knight instead of the bishop we
will never know I think that this is
just not not a very wise trade now
we have two ways to capture and I know
that in the game you capture with the f1
what do you think is the better way do
you think the f1 is the best way or is
it the h1 what do you guys think try to
think of what are the advantages and
disadvantages of each capture in my mind
and I may be wrong but I don't think
that I'm wrong
I think the taking with the h1 would
have been a better choice now why mainly
because I think that in the game when
you capture like this okay you take away
from the center so this pawn might be
missed in the center later on and also I
don't think that I can do anything on
the air file I think that my F file it's
well protected for black and I don't
think I can do something about it I
think that if I would have taken with
the H pawn like so now I think that I
have all kinds of attacking ideas namely
maybe I can push my Jeep on and maybe
even twice so for example let me try to
throw in an idea I'm not saying it's the
best variation okay but just to throw in
some idea let's say black plays here I
play here let's pretend black played
rook c8 whoops
not this move rook c8 I'm not saying
it's the best move I'm just trying to
show you like a possible line and now I
want to play the move g3 what is my idea
my idea is to play King to g2 and bring
the rook over to h1 for the attack on
the H file you guys understand that I
see an open H file I see my look here on
f1 very sleepy and I want to bring my
king up here and bring the rook over
those two points are going to be great
participants in the attack against the
King side right now he cannot not easily
play the move H fly for example because
of this pawn I really like White's
position here I really think that in
this position it's going to be very very
hard maybe you can play something like
not a5 and then maybe I will play King
here let's pretend that he plays Knight
here just pretend I'm not saying it's
the best but maybe pretend and maybe I
can even take it ok and again maybe
black can get too much with his bishop I
don't know yet it's interesting to think
about it but I think that white can hold
I think that rook to h1 is going to be a
real big problem against this as a
matter of fact maybe I can already play
this move like taking here maybe and if
you even think of taking then Luke h1
how to defend that Bishop on 86 I don't
know it doesn't look good maybe you can
play g5 but I can take it I can take it
and then I can take on h6 you see like
for example here I'm gonna go check and
after this and now you can see that the
queen is all over the bishop so I'm just
gonna play something like check and when
you take I'm gonna play Knight takes
pawn double check and my next move is 90
X queen and we can go home with a big
smile on our face right because we're
probably most likely gonna win this game
I agreed looks good okay great so yeah
this is very very unfortunate from
blacks point of view so that's why in
this position in in view of this plan of
taking with the pawn and then advancing
those pawns advancing the King putting
the rook here I have a chance to attack
on the edge fall especially with my
Queen and Bishop already prepared for
that task very very good okay in the
game we played indeed F takes G 396 poem
C 397 again he wants to bring the Knight
to f5 but in this position it's easy to
kick it I think he would have done
better to maybe play the move Knight a5
hitting this bishop and if the bishop
moves to save itself then possibly
Knight see for hitting the Queen and the
bishop I think that this would have been
a much better continuation for block
than what he did
so 97 95 ok a decent move of course
block isn't very interested in taking
with the bishop because then his
daughter scores are gonna be horrible
so Knight f5 ok now my question to you
argent if you had this position one more
time what move would you play anything
different or you'll supply 95 what seems
to be a little maybe more urgent because
I don't see how he's stopping 95 right
it's really really unless he wants to
bring them right back to c6 but then you
can just keep playing useful moves so
what move do you think I should play in
this position I have a move in mind I'm
not 100% sure it's the best but I think
it's it feels right maybe maybe but then
neither 5 I'm not sure I want to take it
in other words if I bring the bishop
from here and he plays Knight a5 let's
try it out let's say Bishop here Knight
f5 and now I have to make a decision
either I move my bishop or I capture I
don't really want to capture because I
really start I'm starting to really like
this Bishop it's really starting to feel
really good on this long diagonal on the
other hand I'm not sure I want to lose
this Bishop so maybe I will play here so
even this position seems to be quite
playable I really really like it maybe
black will have to play 90 sick at some
later point and trying to play 94 right
now he can't of course my bishop is here
White has a better position again look
at the bishop on d7 it's like a prisoner
in jail really really bad
right now it's black to move yeah but
but I think that it's it's really hard
to suggest something useful for black I
really like White's position
fundamentally I can think of a lot of
useful moves here from White's point of
view but again to go back to this
position just for a moment after notice
the opponent played Knight here what do
you think he is saying where is this
Knight heading well we cannot know where
it's heading what Square is he gonna
land on soon say it yes and on f5 it's a
pretty good piece right at least for a
moment can I do something about it can I
do something how can I stop him yes yeah
once again this move can prove to be a
very annoying move if you are the black
player because this move is doing a lot
of damage it doesn't let you play h5
ever so this is always going to be kind
of a weakness because if you ever play
it father just take it and in the
meantime the knight is not coming to its
optimal square of fiv just made this
move with the
only reason to come here and you're
telling him nah no stay
that is always annoying to see if you
are trying to get your piece somewhere
and the opponent is preventing it okay
so let's continue with the game
after night here 95 night at 590 xd7 now
Arjen here you're gonna get really
scolded by me you know what that means
I'm gonna really yell at you not really
yell at you but like do this to you
because when I'm looking at the night
and I'm looking at the bishop I know you
might have heard two bishops right you
say oh if I have two bishop that's gonna
be great but when you look at the black
bishop on b7 does he impress you do you
look at the bishop on d7 and say oh my
god does the bishop that's gonna make me
ya know exactly the opposite I look at
the bishop on d7 I'm thinking dude
during jail and you're not getting out
of jail there is no way to get the
bishop even if it was a bughouse game if
I could just pick up that Bishop and put
it somewhere where am I going to put it
there's no legal way to get it out of
that chain look at all the black pawns
the a6 pawn the b5 pawn the d5 pawn and
the e6 pawn they all have one thing in
common they're all keep this Bishop d7
prisoner and he's not gonna be running
that knight on e5 sitting pretty in the
center and it's almost like it's not
like a teasing night it's always saying
to the bishop take me capture me and
black says now I don't want to capture
because I have to have this bishop if I
give you this bishop and put a white
pawn here my position is gonna look like
Swiss cheese all the dark squares are
gonna look horrible so that's another
reason it's like a good night and a bad
Bishop we do not want to trade that good
piece for bad pieces now we know that
right now the bishop on e3 may not be
the best piece in the world but if I
brought it here let's say away from the
range of the night what will be my next
move potentially what move do I have now
on my list of ideas because I don't like
this Knight on f5 right the knight on f5
is kind of annoying it's like the best
black piece right now
so what can I do to it how can I harass
it by playing the move
for now g4 is begging to be played so
let's say if black plays that say sir
move and I'm gonna go Bam Bam the knight
is to go back I really start again with
every move I'm starting to like more and
more the white position he's attacking
he has more space his pieces are more
valuable squares the only piece that
doesn't do much is the bishop on b3 but
rest assured that in like one move let's
say this Knight goes back and guess
who's coming to dinner
the bishop is ready the bishop goes to
c2 and he's already on the diagonal now
I have ideas like maybe pushing my H
pawn like h4 and then h5 completely
weakening this whole structure now white
is sitting pretty and I would if I had
this position with white and I didn't
win my game I would be extremely
disappointed because I would feel that I
have a great position here so g4 is my
favorite move or rather prepared g4 move
my bishop first I want to preserve this
Bishop if I play g4 immediately he will
just take my bishop and I kind of like
my bishop and especially I like it on f4
so okay Knight takes D 7 are you gonna
play Knight d7 next game in the position
like this but just I don't think so
how about certainly not certainly not
the knight is much better than the
bishop and leave me so of course he took
and then Bishop c2 and then he took on
e3 okay and queen takes all right so we
have traded two pieces and I think that
why traded two of his favorite pieces
for blacks last favorite pieces and
therefore the position is now kind of I
think it's okay from black I think that
notice the bishop is not there anymore
the terrible bishop is like imagine if
you had like a little booboo a little
wound somewhere and all of a sudden is
out how glad you are right you're happy
same thing here that Bishop was so
terrible so okay now this move is too
much right now I think listen when you
play a move like this then the e6 square
looks really weak
and besides what kind of Bishop does
white have a light square bishop do you
think that black needs even more light
square points to be on the light squares
I don't think so I think there maybe you
want to put some on a dollar squares so
yeah this move is a bit too ambitious I
think this is a good move the real girls
from north to the file now all of a
sudden that pawn on e6 needs some
babysitting that's true and now you play
the move king h1 I have to tell you that
I didn't quite understand why I'm not
sure I understand exactly why we need to
do that is it really that important to
to put the King on h1 I think it was
sometimes it's what we call in chess at
least I call it just a lazy move it's
like you play like I moved because I
don't know what to do and therefore I'll
just oh let me just move my King to the
corner maybe it'll be saved there but
maybe I want to leave the King right
here because I don't want to waste a
tempo so what would be a good move what
would be White's plan right now this
bishop on c2 looks really really sleepy
and the black King side looks a little
loose this is not a super strong pawn
this is not a super strong pawn so I
really want to play a move like this now
I don't know if I can do it right now if
I do it right now
he might just snack on it take it and
then it's like okay and now what what is
my next trick you know if I try to
attack the pawn on g6 then he always
says stuff like rook air-five so I'm not
100% sure that this is a smart thing to
do although maybe even this is possible
maybe now there's a way to play
something like Queen g3 or something
like that maybe it's worth it and then
you somehow take the poll later on but I
wouldn't even bother I would just
prepare it so for example maybe I can
play a move like Queen to f3 to throw in
a move I mean now I am ready to play the
move g4 let's say my opponent plays a
move again just for the just to throw in
a move I'm not saying it's the best move
but that's a rookie 7 G for now my my
position is improving
I am pressuring it if you take and I
take back the pawn on g6 is going to be
very much in trouble you won't be able
to defend the pawn on g6 the one
next to the king right here so you
cannot even take me and if you can't
take me then it's great I mean we just
want improving my position I'm gaining
space at the right time I want to take
here because every capture and then of
course I have another Jeep on I have a
second Jeep on to push when I need to
and that will make all those Jeep on
pushes and captures I'm gonna make my
bishop on c2 look like it means
something right like it's a valuable
piece so okay so we have King edge oops
sorry King h1h five Wow all the black
pawns are on light squares just like the
bishop hope for them okay so Bishop d3 I
guess the bishop is improving his
position a little bit okay Bishop
eight-six
I don't think this is the greatest move
in the world because the Queen has to
move anyways Queen e2 again I'm really
thinking of playing a move like in
between f3 I like it's kind of better I
like the Queen to be in touch with more
stuff in the center and again maybe my
plan is going to be to try to push the
pawn somehow h3 and g4 for that sake I'd
rather have my King on g1 okay the game
is not super exciting but it got
exciting okay Bishop back who knows why
a4 that was a very very brave decision I
think I think that if you wanted to play
a four you could have done it but maybe
you could have prepared it as well if
you wanted to play the move a four then
I'm thinking that in this position okay
maybe you could have played it right
here instead of Bishop d3 a4 of course I
don't think you have any reason to be
afraid of a capture because you just
swing you look back to here and on your
next move that pawn on a4 is going
bye-bye so yeah so you could have done
that probably under better circumstances
okay so we had this this this this it
took and you took and he played Queen b6
okay Bishop e5 rooked
a eight and now you took it upon me six
yeah why not all of a sudden all his
pawn became a little vulnerable and he
traded and
traded rook here attacking your Bishop
Bishop c6 rook a5 defending the pawn on
d5 and so you said okay then I'm
defending my pawn on Beecher
so there were a little fireworks both
side traded some shots and in this
position I like I think that white is in
really good shape mainly because he's up
a pawn and now we can see that all those
pawns are on light squares that means
that they can be attacked okay in this
position he played here okay probably
the only move I don't think he has
anything else I really like this move
takes and of course that was a little
accident right that was a little problem
so could we have done something else in
this position what do you think would
have been a good alternative to a3 first
of all I have to say that in this
position maybe in view of what happened
you could have played something else but
again the a for pawn for black I think
is gonna be too dangerous
so after this move here oh I was about
to suggest a move but now I'm thinking
that it's really not that good oh so
maybe let's go back a little bit here
after this yes Arjun but then you can
still play a3 and then you might play a
2 and you'll play rook a 1 I agree let's
take a look at it yes I I'm definitely
interested in looking at let's put the
rook here I know it's a bit passive but
maybe this is the best way because if
you get made at well we know this is not
ideal right so now what can he do we
cannot attack you further your main idea
right now is to play Bishop to EI t'
right you want to play Bishop e8 and
then he has to kiss those pawns goodbye
can you all see that Bishop coming here
and the pawn on g6 and then all the
black pawns are gonna fall so let's try
this and of course we're gonna play b4
very very strong move not only saving
the pawn but at the same time keeping an
eye on the rock let's say he plays a two
we're gonna play this move and now I'm
thinking to myself that white is again
in good shape maybe this was the way to
go probably Black has only one movie is
to save his rook so maybe Brooke a3 try
to tickle the pawn oops sorry trying to
tickle the pawn on c3 right I want to
try to take it but at the same time
guess what I'm gonna take the pollinate
you but I don't want to get made it so
let's try to think what would we what
can we do in this position
can i play Bishop 8 or am I going to be
too late for this I am Not sure I have
to be really careful because blacks idea
is to take the pawn on c3 then with the
bishop take the pawn on d4 and then of
course the queenie square here could be
lots and lots of trouble so let's try to
think what is White's best move here yes
in say again please
yes absolutely absolutely but the thing
is my plan was to play Bishop here and
in this case I'm not worried about this
because I'm gonna play check King moves
and take and I'm covering b1
see now I'm defending the b1 square with
my bishop and with my rock so I want two
pawns and I think that here I'm okay but
my concern was in this variation head I
had I played this move that he will take
here and now I'm not at liberty to take
on a2 because rook c1 checkmate and of
course I can take this pawns but the
question is by him keeping this am i
tempting fate a little bit is this too
dangerous you know could this this could
be maybe too dangerous so I think in
this position after this maybe White has
to do something can I defend all my
stuff somehow though I don't know that
but he's gonna take on c3 and attack my
bishop
no I cannot play rookie 3 because he's
gonna take on d4 and now there's a pin
you see if I take he gets to take here
yes well I mean it was I think it was if
you mean in this position and here you
will take first on the 8 here if you
play rugby 3 here you're too late
because I take both pawns but if you
take here I was thinking about it but
I'm not this is the relation that I said
it looks a little crazy
take take giving up an exchange for the
sake of playing here but I think that
I'm just in time to play this map and I
think that somehow here I'm I'm somehow
alive not happily alive but alive
probably it's ok so yeah I mean this is
this is probably the origin you're right
and rugby one for better word for worse
you have to have tried it and again
probably the continuation is forced a 2
here here
and now ok I can play either one of
those moves so let's see maybe I can
play well can i play this move let's
check it out and then after look here
play b5 so I'm saving my pawn and I'm
saving my bishop at the same time of
course the question is can he play
Bishop takes d4 and I'm thinking ok then
I play rook takes a 2 and I think that
white is fine maybe not more than that
but white is fine this position I think
that I'm able to defend everything if
you move this rook then I'm just gonna
move my rock so quite a wild game margin
a wild game lots of opportunities right
for both sides have you learned
something from this game good did you
guys understand that game more or less
yeah ok I think our time is just about
up and
like we saw in the game in the end there
was a bit of a after this well didn't we
take some how how did that happen
oh yeah after this here yep
and so busy thinking about the Queenie
and the pawns and the weaknesses right
did you forget that the King is a bit
stuck
now I see so you forget that the work
can just go to the last time that
happened okay guys thank you very much
for your time